and you know where my original 1980 Han
Solo is how the hell am I supposed to
know where one action figure from your
Harrison Ford shrine is
oh shit
I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark
I love my eyes not one time
you
Laura Croft Tomb Raider starring
Angelina Jolie directed by Simon West
the greatest film ever made welcome to
my hilarious 'ti review of Laura Croft
Tomb Raider which is my biggest guilty
pleasure movie of all time
this movie is dumb it's stupid I'm well
aware it's not good but my god do I love
it I love everything about this movie
I've watched this movie three times in
the past year it's I'm actually slightly
ashamed to say that guy's hilarious
''tis to me can be different things it
can be a movie that's such an atrocity
it's hilarious so bad that it's good or
maybe it's just so bad that it's
hilarious that it was even made like
save Battlefield Earth but there is that
rare film that you fully recognize is a
terrible movie but you don't care and
that for me is Laura Croft Tomb Raider
so let's talk about this movie why is it
so special to me
well it came out of the perfect time for
me the year 2001 I was exactly 13 years
old this movie was made for me I grew up
playing the Laura Croft games I loved a
lot of these games and I've loved
watching the games mature into the games
they are today at the time of this
movie's release it was the
highest-grossing female-driven action
film of all time and as far as video
game adaptations go this is by far my
favorite of all of them I mean there
isn't really that much competition now I
feel the need to reiterate this before I
start talking about the movie again I
know this is not a good movie but my god
I don't give a shit you know who
actually agreed with me that would be
mr. Roger Ebert check out this quote
from him did I enjoy the movie yes is it
up there with the Indiana Jones pictures
no but did I grin with delight at the
absurdity of it all you betcha
Ebert you understand you understand me
Angelina Jolie was the perfect choice to
play Lara Croft there is no better
choice in my mind I can't imagine
another person perfectly embodying this
character as she did not only does she
look like her but she just got the feel
of it all down the sexiness the fun the
adventure what I love about her
character is that she's always
she never appears annoyed or angry she's
always having fun on her incredibly
over-the-top adventures that make no
sense yeah this movie makes no sense it
I just watched it I took a lot of notes
it doesn't make sense this this movies
it's really dumb I don't care by the way
please take a drink every time I say
this movie stupid but I don't care
you'll get really hammered trust me so
what is Tomb Raider have to offer well
it's a early 2000s action film featuring
things like this flipping on wires
Angelina Jolie's thighs more flipping on
wires and a scene that actually takes
place on wires and Daniel Craig's
American accent the place is coming down
oh and there's more trust me this is so
much more the opening scene this movie
is so fucking awesome Angelina Jolie is
fighting with this robot and just watch
this moment just just watch it and tell
me it's not the coolest thing you've
ever seen in your entire life
I mean did you not just cry oh I love
this fucking mommy so much one thing
you'll notice early on this movie has a
ton of drum and bass music it was super
popular in the late 90s to early 2000s
and they really utilized it in this film
now it was 13 when this movie came out
and as you know I respect women I
respect women a lot I married a
wonderful woman but this scene is just
it's just a little too much especially
at age 13 it was just a little too much
for a little Chris to handle little
Chris had some fun little Chris liked
that scene big Chris likes it too so
what's the plot of Lara Croft Tomb
Raider well the Illuminati are after
some artifacts that when you combine
them it creates like this time-bending
portal that lets you go back in time and
alter things but only when the planetary
alignment occurs because you know who
really gives a shit there's a backstory
with Lara Croft's father played by jon
voigt or just so happens to be her
real-life father and that gave her
character some weight and I gotta say
this you know they really actually tried
they really did try with this movie this
wasn't just a quick cash grab you can
tell they're actually trying to make a
fun movie there's a scene early on in
this movie where Lara's Butler says this
line Egypt again nothing but pyramids
and sand I know gets everywhere in the
cracks and it got me thinking this movie
came out in 2001 they made a joke about
sand getting in all the cracks and it
was like a sort of sexual innuendo this
movie came out a year before another
film that made a very similar remark I
don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere did
George Lucas see Tomb Raider and decide
to write a sexual innuendo about sand I
can't help but love to feel this movie
it's like it's like what if Indiana
Jones was a woman and no it's actually
better than national treasure and it
came out before national treasure so
yeah it's like those two films that both
kind of ripped the Indiana Jones old
classic serial adventure style
personally I feel
Lara Croft's a better film it's just
it's more fun national treasure maybe
has better production values perhaps and
maybe is a more coherent film but I
personally have way more fun watching
this movie than I have watching national
treasure that's the honest truth so
Laura finds a clock in this hidden room
that just starts ticking for no reason
this whole mystery surrounding this
clock starts and it's kind of fun and I
just love it and that sounds like a
great goosebumps title mystery of the
clock
sorry Lara Croft and Lara pulls no
punches while driving in traffic I mean
she's doing like a full-on Matrix
Reloaded in normal everyday traffic
she's not being chased by anybody she
just she really doesn't like waiting you
know and she probably has like a good
out of jail free card with all the cops
so here's we were introduced to Daniel
Craig yes Daniel Craig was in this movie
before he got huge it's kind of cool
when you read watch it because you have
to Rader and James Bond teaming up in
the same movie but what's unfortunate is
that everyone in this movie has a
British accent some of these people are
not British for whatever reason they
gave the one guy who's definitely
British an American accent and Wow it
doesn't work
is Daniel Craig please just stick with
the British
so Powell in this film is like the main
villain he's this villain
you know it's like he's just a bad guy
they wrote him down like powell AKA
bad guy he's just like the cliched like
oh yes i will be all-powerful he's just
you know he's that villain who's just so
poorly written just kind of like a
throwaway villain but his assistant mr.
Pimm's reminds me of Wes Anderson my
friend brought it up he was like that
looks like Wes Anderson and I was just
like oh my god no I can't not see Wes
Anderson in between tapes he was just
building little miniatures to to film so
what does Laura Croft do in her spare
time
well she bungee jumps inside of her
house I mean this is obviously just a
scene you know that just show us her her
ballet there's there's no one coming to
attack her house that would set up an
awesome bungee cord action scene yeah
there is
to be honest I actually really like this
scene like actually if like from a
critical like viewpoint of how its film
like it's it's stupid and dumb and fun
but like just looking at how it's filmed
and edited this is a really good action
scene and of course in the post matrix
world of 2001 they had to have her do a
wall running scene I mean it's over the
top in every single way and it's all the
better for it I mean what other movie
has this and when she gets on her
motorcycle it's just so beautiful and
this brings me to one of my favorite
moments in the entire movie and
describing it would not do it justice
you just have to see it perfection so
what does powell do in his spare time
well I mean you know he meditates what
else would you do if you were a bad guy
so Laura gets a cryptic message sent by
her dead father that sets her on more of
an adventure and we get to see her in
the jungle running around and anyone
else this would not be cool but to
anyone who played the games just seeing
Lara Croft running around in a jungle
like environment is just it's so cool so
every main character in the movie the
bad guy Daniel Craig and Angelina Jolie
converged on our first tomb that needs
raiding and during this scene the
world's longest one minute happens where
Daniel Craig is just counting down this
minute and I think it's actually more
like maybe two minutes he's like 45 44
two minutes later 40 39 and Laura you
just go ahead and ride that thing uh I
don't know what it is but but man can
she ride it now while they're trying to
solve this riddle with these different
pieces that have to fit together in all
these right spots they bring to life
these stone creatures that just pop out
of the walls and grab swords and a giant
statue of the god Vishnu that comes
alive and smiles as very important it
smiles the funny thing about this is
that they're all just like oh that's
normal but it
all fine because we get to see Lara
Croft do this
this movie is so fucking awesome
thank you everyone who made this movie
so after this sequence ends Lara visits
some sort of strange temple which she
gets healed by like magic tea and it
just reminded me of the opening of Ace
Ventura when nature calls now my biggest
issue with this movie like you know real
problem not just like it's stupid and
dumb is characters I don't know how they
get places scenes just start with
characters together they just knew where
everyone was and they just all converge
like it happens a lot or they just know
everything and where everyone's gonna be
and they just pile up in a room all this
unreal like how did you find out that
that person with your magical you're a
magical person aren't you
how do you do that and somehow they all
converge as I said and travel to Siberia
but it's okay because look at this money
shot just look at how much awesomeness
is crammed into one shot just look at it
so here Laura gets cryptic advice from a
young girl who disappears this is the
second time this has happened in the
movie I didn't mention it earlier but
there's like a girl in the jungle who
like leads her so it's like a thing in
this movie she gets weird advice from
young ghostly girls there's no
explanation
it just happens so we get to the big
finale location where they discover a
big model of the solar system which
leads to a time-bending showdown with
Powell and Croft which is filled with
just tons of awesomeness and a hilarious
shot of them running up a pyramid
together in some sort of strange void
but once lower talks to her father in
this strange time-bending universe and
feels better about herself she comes
back into the real world and is able to
grab a knife in midair and turn it
around to have it fly right back at
Powell and then they have a big fight
scene with Laura crop kicks his ass and
does this crazy throat chop move and
you're just like boom fucking years yeah
well on a serious note though in the
next scene she dogsleds out on her boots
that's on a serious note it is kind of
cool though when she finds the dogs
she says this which is a tribute to any
time in the game lore would find an item
and she would go mm-hmm
does any of this make sense uh-huh do I
care no because this shot
if this movie wasn't already a perfect
guilty pleasure
it ends with a freeze-frame just so you
know all movies a 10 with a freeze-frame
are perfect
honestly the late last year I got a
group my friends together these are
hardcore like jaded film lovers like
they've seen tons of movies they go to a
lot of movies with me and I set them
down for this movie and afterwards they
all had to admit this movie's a ton of
fun pop in Tomb Raider one day and just
have fun with it it's a well-made
dumbass movie and in my opinion the best
video game adaptation ever made if you
guys want me to in the future I'll talk
about the sequel Cradle of Life and
another hilarious 'ti review guys I
really hope you enjoyed this I had fun
talking about I had to I have a poster
of this movie in my basement my wife and
I on our wedding cake had artistic
renderings of Laura Croft and Indiana
Jones sitting on top of our wedding cake
if you've never seen it give it a watch
it's tons of fun guys thank you so much
for watching this I will have more
hilarious tea reviews for you very soon
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes